firstly
danny kong she is a double world junior
track
cycling champion and multiple european
and british champion she's currently
racing with lots of sudan welcome danny
are you there
are you with us
hi hi hi
okay
and next
we have um
marie divine guamitakina she is the
world junior 500 meters track
sprint time child champion of 2019
and she speaks with us from paris france
with the assistance of my interpreter
nautica
bonjour marie
hi oh hiya great to see you
great to see you okay i try to put my
camera
on let's see if you can put your camera
on for us so we can see you
i can't because um you have to put my
camera on
okay i'm gonna help you to do that in a
moment okay
um
right that's going to help you now
hopefully technology's brilliant hiya
this is great i love that i love this
this is brilliant
um okay nice to meet you it's fantastic
that you're here
um and it's brilliant that you're that
you're gonna be sharing your experiences
with
with danny next we have
charlotte cole hussein a double british
cycling champion
of the bellow club de laundress london
welcome shot
are you there
hi yeah perfect nico
brilliant charlotte and finally
we have rihanna paris smith she's a
hugely talented
rising star of track sprint who is
currently racing
a team terminator hi rena
are you there hi marlon good evening
everyone
oh perfect there you are great here we
are
and let me just here i am as well
okay hey and we have nausica there as
well brilliant
wow oh yeah i can't see rihanna
i can't see rihanna for some reason oh
oh there she is yes i can't see myself
but i can see
rhiannon say that's a bonus well i mean
isn't this the first time you've used
zoom danny it is
can you believe that especially in the
last year is the first time
i am on the i think um you might want to
go i think on the
i'm not sure where it will be but if you
click gallery view you will be able to
see everyone all at once
instead of just the person talking oh
yes i've got
everybody and i've got a little arrow so
i can scroll up and down and
i'm sure i'll figure it out well say
hello to everybody hiya
marie charlotte hi everybody
hey look this is so unique it's so
exciting i mean i don't think
i don't think anybody's ever put
together such uh
such a fantastic panel as this champion
cyclists young
powerful women and um i'm i'm the lucky
ones who have done so
um i'm god blessed in that respect
um welcome to this discussion it's it's
a fantastic time to be talking about
women in cycling there's a lot of things
going on
over the last couple of weeks or so in
the media about women's voices
in the sport but particularly for me i'm
really interested to understand about
as i said b-a-m-e women's experiences in
the sport from
grassroots to to elite
international level and in in here i
have two
world champions um a double national
champion
and an aspirant racist cyclist
looking to become a champion as well
i think i think um i think um
let me just um double check that
everybody can
um see this screen for a second before i
go on
um let me see i'll make sure that
everyone can see
uh
should be able to see everything yeah so
let me just ask you first of all about
how you got into the sport
um let me just ask you how you going to
support so maybe i can start with
um maybe i can start with you um
you uh danny how did you get into it how
did you get into cycling
uh so for me my uh cycling journey
actually began through
um doing another sport so i was a short
track speed skater
from the age of eight and i worked my
way up to competing for
great britain and trained with the
national team at the national eye center
in nottingham
um and when i was 14 years old
i couldn't do the off-ice training
um the short track speed skaters do a
lot of running plyometric
jumping bass work um to help aid
their on ice work
due to having orage good slatters which
is
quite a common problem that most
uh children at that sort of age
experience due to doing
a lot of a lot of sport and
uh basically what happens is uh you
you're growing at such a rate that your
muscles can't
keep up essentially and then it starts
to put on tendons you get sore knees
so that's where a bike was a perfect
tool which
my dad got for me um didn't really
have any idea how to work the gears i
was very
i was an amateur basically um he took me
to the local
uh park which we happen to discover a
circuit a cycling circuit built
specifically
for cycling so again that was just
a fluke we didn't have no idea it was
there it was two miles from my house it
backed right behind my school we didn't
know it was there
um and another flute was that sally hall
cycling club
were there doing a session so me and my
dad rocked her
and they invited us to join the
following tuesday
um and it was from there really that
they discovered i had a lot of
horsepower but kind of didn't really
know anything about cycling how to use
the bike
um and that's where they introduced me
to a whole range of
disciplines and opened my eyes really
but it was the track that
i got hooked to straight away um and i
used a club trap bike and did a lot of
the dhl sprint schools and
rsrs so the regional school of racing
run by british cycling
and that's how i really got a taste for
the track and from there really that's
how
my story began never look back
what a fantastic story and um
you had a cycling track which was close
to where you lived
and you were able to join him join or
join that club without any issues
no problems you were warmly welcomed
yeah
very warmly welcome um 500 plus members
at the time which again
wasn't to my knowledge uh until you
kind of happen to discover the the uh
the coaches and they inform you with
that so it really opened my eyes because
other than
uh watching the london 2012 olympic
games i
really didn't know much at all about
cycling yeah
no it's brilliant brilliant introduction
and it's a nice it's a nice transition
and
talking about rsrs and having a local
club
um that was you know quite close to
where you lived
charlotte um how did you get into it are
there any
is there any sense of resemblance with
danny's story in your story
uh yeah really similar i mean mine
wasn't um mine wasn't accidental my dad
uh cycled a lot when he was younger he
competed in cycling um before his
kids were got in the way um and then
we uh and then he took us down to the
velodrome a couple of times when we were
really young so i was about eight years
old i believe when i first rode at home
hill
which is my local wardrobe uh and
so yeah and after that we just kind of
started making it
[Music]
weekly thing it's interesting that you i
didn't know you were a short track
skater though because i did i dabbled
very much dabbled in in ice skating when
i was young there's a
an ice rink really really close to us so
i used to go on sundays and i used to
really really enjoy it
and i remember when i originally i first
had to kind of choose between
what i was going to do on a on a sunday
whether i was going to continue
doing ice skating at a very low level i
mean honestly it was just like an open
public session or going at the track
um yeah a very similar way local
velodrome
um welcoming club that i i joined almost
as soon as
well after a couple of sessions there
yes again a welcoming club
um and you had the opportunity to do
am i skating like danny but you know you
stopped
um and you had your father involved
in getting you into the sport with a
friendly club the vcl
i wonder marie did you have any
influence from your
father in coming into cycling
it's a little bit different because on
my family nobody
do cycling i start
when i was four years old
i started at the at the
at the club of my city um
at the beginning it was just for for
game it's uh
it was really fun with my with my
friends um
every wednesday we have training but
it's
really really fun at the beginning um
year after year i continue i progress um
i know the track uh when i was 12 years
old
and it was just like
baptism listening i don't know
christening yes baptism yes
baptism christening just for for know
the track and
know how to to to
ride on the track when i was 12 years
old
um i had like an induction
yes exactly yeah um
i had incredible experience in this
sport
and and uh
and yes it was it was pretty i i could
never have imagined uh
all this when i started cycling at four
years old
yeah it sounds like the three of you
have had a joyous introduction
into cycling with clubs and going to the
track and um
i just want to ask you a question marie
so i've read a bit about you said
a cycling school no
no okay i must have read one thing
i think no okay
i i thought that um i thought that then
in in some parts of france that there
were certain schools from
associate that had different
associations with different sports
because always
i thought i thought that was a case but
no
okay by talking about that
how did you get the sport of cycling was
it similar to
danny charlotte marie or you know
probably take a bit from all three to be
honest um
i always used to go on my bike my little
i don't have a piece of cycle we always
[ __ ] want to cycle
uh and i did it more as a hobby and i
say it's my thing
for you to be a sprinter on a different
track on a running track on a red track
um yeah i loved that when i was a little
kid really good attitude
good community great coach and i just
never
i never was quick enough basically to
make it on the big league so i was
looking at colleges
um once i finished school um didn't know
what i wanted to do and i came across
a college oakland college uh which did
cycling academy alongside uh
education so i just thought i mean we
just were all just going
for the trial we went we went to the
opening evening and
just the guy who run it was like
interested so i came for a trial
uh he basically just took me under his
wing because i just found me what clips
were
um i didn't know that was the difference
between junior
senior year playing uh yeah jazz uh took
me under his win
and uh he sort of showed me a bit back
before
um and then i got into it that way and
then i
got onto the track i did my track
accreditation when i was 15 or 16 at
barbie
and then it sort of went off from there
really
wow so that's the oakland's
cycling academy um rihanna
yeah and whereabouts is that libraries
and organs in hochschule
hartfordshire yeah it sounds like a
fantastic opportunity
um for the young people to sort of go
and do their studies and do
the sport that they love as well okay
um let me ask you a question that you
can all respond to
um two questions really
first question um is um for young
um females coming into the sport of
cycling um
is it a dad and daughter thing
is it the passion of your father that's
driving this or
or are you pushing it yourself or or
whatever
what do you think for me i would say um
okay
charlotte sorry i would say um
you know as with anything you probably
can't you can't have a
use like a blanket statement like that
um it happens to be the case i think
that a lot of people who get because
it's
um kind of as as uh well most of us
touched on it's quite a
difficult sport to get into you sort of
have to stumble upon it or you'll get
into it
through your um through your
someone who introduces you to it a lot
of people who who
got into cycling and like maybe the
majority of cyclists i know
it's from their parents were cycling um
and because more
uh men do sport than women especially
20 30 years ago it tends to be the case
that a lot of people
who a lot of girls who come into cycling
will have come into cycling through
their fathers but
it's it's it's obviously not always the
case i think um
you know in the future we'll be less so
as long as we do our job in promoting
cycling
oh sure marie did you want to say about
your father
and his influence in cycling or
non-influence
not cycling the particularly because my
love
my father love very fun love the
the sport in general so when i was young
i started by
cycling but i am i try a lot of sport
like
football et cetera
and um he
always
encourages you push
yes push me for for the sport and i was
i was strong at cycling so she post he
passed me to to do cycling
okay okay um let me get go to the next
question and maybe i'll start with with
danny and then rihanna so
in terms of you going to these spaces to
to do cycling with your
bam e heritage um
did you see any any other faces like
yours in these spaces and
um if so what was it like and if not you
know did you have any feelings about
that at the time
danny um i mean i didn't obviously i was
at
a young age 14 so you don't tend to pay
attention to
um issues should i say such as that
um for me it was just about learning to
ride a bike and focusing on
on that perspective really so nothing
entered my mind from that and i just got
stuck in i was very welcomed everyone
was so
friendly and helpful and yeah i kind of
a lot back to
the club really because i don't think
i'd probably be sitting here today if it
weren't for
for them being so welcoming and um also
obviously my dad being
a brilliant support so brilliant
rihanna same question yeah
uh different family this stuff is a
different experience feels
sort of i'll never forget i went to sort
of the first sort of club
experience and it was in a field and we
were driving up this
um sort of this like path to get out
there and me and my dad drove him
and everyone just sort of stared at me
you'd think they lost school you know
it was a bit like oh dad why is everyone
looking at us like
looks like like she seems to understand
okay and then um yeah it was just
the
yeah so there was a sense of hype of
hyper visibility
that you felt eyes are on you in that
respect okay
charlotte marie um did you did you have
any sense of your
um ethnic heritage when you walked into
those spaces or
or what were you like danny were you
like rihanna
charlotte um well
you know again lucky enough at hern hill
it's relatively diverse as well
um so and obviously when i when i was
eight years old i wasn't really paying
attention to that
um but as you grow up and
you start going to kind of the
national level races um
it it you do kind of there does come a
point when you notice
uh that i i can't i can't ever tell if
if people looked at me
uh because of because i have you know
slightly darker skin all
because i i'm i normally like wear weird
stuff
so it's hard to tell on that on that
side but you do kind of notice that
there's not many other people who
look like you i yeah um danny's a couple
years older than me so i always knew
her as being you know that's quite cool
and there's a couple of people
at my age as well who were also
non-white
so um it didn't feel completely
isolating and i didn't feel like i was
you know picked on really by my peers at
least
um but you do you do kind of notice i
think once you get old enough you notice
that this
uh especially growing up in london you
know just when i go to these races these
national level races it doesn't look
like the demographic of
when i go when i walk around you know
stratum or
anywhere in london really so okay
okay so i'll come to um marie in a
moment but just to go back on what you
and danny
said that it was you know you um
certainly for you charlie you said that
you know that
there was some possible um
you know there was a possible sense of
of of of seeing
um your ethnic identity through the eyes
of some people
in that respect and but you know for for
rihanna i was going to ask whether
um you was there any sense of was there
a support system in place for you
um to support you through that sense of
hypervisit
hyper visibility that you were speaking
of uh
through my family and my like support
network because obviously yeah
my parents were probably my first in
line otherwise it might be their
grandparents that aren't demonstrated
but
definitely for my parents you like that
we just speak like
and it sort of realized because
obviously came from our flags where it's
probably opposite and then i came into
sykes and i was like whoa
well yeah um so yeah it was it
soon realized it was just the norm that
there wasn't really many people who look
like you yeah okay that's an interesting
thing there
and marie what about your experience um
um you know did you have any sense of um
being more visible than others
in in the sport when you first came to a
club
um
it's a local it's a local one so
when i started cycling with my friend my
friend was a
black and when we
go at the competition we can
saw the difference um
my club is was really
many you know the white people
black people cultural indian
[Music]
yes so there was a definitely a
diversity within her club
yeah whenever she went to compete there
was an awareness that
it was not the norm that other clubs
were mainly dominated by
yeah no brilliant that's that's a real
fantastic insight because what you're
saying is that with a multicultural club
there's
um obviously an education of of of you
know of
under you know perhaps a greater
understanding of ethnic diversity but
when your club
moves away from that particular local
different part of the country
and it's perhaps more monocultural
that's where
those um differences may be exposed more
and that's yeah that's that's something
that could that can
learn from especially in in the uk as
well where
we have you know in london birmingham
glasgow where there might be more
multicultural than other spaces around
the country how to
how do we enable people to um
um be appreciative of the fact that
they're that they might find themselves
living in a bubble
and there's a bigger world outside of
different sorts of people
um with different ethnic backgrounds so
that's that's
we've had some some brilliant insights
from everybody there thanks very much
for that
but i kind of realized as well that um
this is the first time
you guys have met i think um i don't
think you've met before
have you got any questions for each
other maybe you know maybe
i mean danny do you want to ask anybody
any any questions about their
about their cycling and you know the
successes and
the highs and lows of being a young
woman
in the sport danny um well my question
was for charlotte and it was actually
um well a topic that um is
quite important but a bit off topic for
what we've
just been chatting about it it's about
food so i always find it really
interesting
uh with fueling strategies obviously
science and sport are sponsoring this
which obviously you'd use pre-during
post-race for recovery um
but in terms of uh what would you have
leading up to a big race charlotte the
week before a few days before
the day before um compared to what would
you indulge on as like a cheat meal i
mean i know this is totally different to
what we've been talking about but
i find it really interesting what people
have to say about this so
well this is um this is going to be
going back quite a while now because i
haven't raced
some time but uh well
you know i did my last couple of seasons
uh as a vegetarian so
it's obviously trickier you know you
want to make sure you get in the
amount of protein etc um almost
and i i will say i wasn't as good with
nutrition
as um lots of other people because i
kind of
such as i don't really i didn't
yeah i wasn't so good at taking anything
seriously but that's not to say that i
just eat trash but it would mean that i
just kind of um
i wouldn't go the other way and eat only
like bulgur wheat forever
um my the go-to would be a pasta
i really struggle to eat lots on on race
day i just you think you get
nerves and um that just make you not
wanna
even at breakfast don't eat very much so
it'd be like a coffee
definitely maybe two maybe some cereal
or something but
um during racing is when i have the most
um
kind of specific uh specific
desires or the most specific um
routine or whatever i can't remember you
know
um those little banana serene bars
oh yes bunch of them in my back pocket
definitely and i'm not just saying this
definitely an sis
orange gel sis
they're more substantial like bigger
than a lot of the other gels sometimes i
have a gel and i think this isn't going
to get me very far
um and then i just have kind of
like i don't yeah um i never really did
energy drinks or anything and then after
the race is basically um
whatever i fancy because by then it's
it's it's time to
have fun a bit but the interesting thing
is and i don't know if other people have
this that um
i never had cravings for like um bad
food after i race i feel like you feel
kind of
you know you feel like adrenaline and
like kind of healthy and i always have a
craving for like something relatively
clean
i never really have here to indulge
so uh yeah yeah that's that's pretty
much
oh that was yeah interesting i uh yeah
no i
need to say about cravens actually
because whenever i finish a race i crave
salt and vinegar crisps i don't know
whether it's because i'm a heavy sweater
not to be too graphic
but um i must use a lot of salt because
i just have this
like craving that i've gotta eat salt
and vinegar crisps so
before anything else
charlotte do you have a question for um
anyone in this group that you know
you've not met before that you might you
know just curious to know about their
lifestyles and cycling salt and vinegar
crisps uh
that's that's that's an interesting one
danny
charlotte have you got a question for
anyone uh yeah um
uh marie divine can i can i ask how i
should pronounce your name
yes how do you pronounce your name
but marry divine it's it's good too okay
because i want to break okay so marie
devin
um so well my my
question is kind of a bit more uh heavy
i suppose
um so when i look at the when i look at
the um
most non-white riders in especially the
men's peloton the men's professional
peloton and even in
men's uh and track cycling as well
a lot of the black riders and non-white
riders come from france
um i know that's because there's a lot
of
uh there's a quite a there's quite a
diverse country um of the european
countries but
um the uk is also a very diverse country
but we don't have very many
if any high-level um black riders
and i'm wondering whether there is
something that is done
in france that whether the cycling
federation or the support system
at a lower level all the way up to elite
level is
is is better in france whether the um
there's a you know whether whether it's
what the reason for york for being more
diverse
um what where that comes from if you
think there's anything that france does
particularly well
in that respect um um
i think it's because in french we have a
a lot of origin and
the lesson
is
okay so um basically there's some kind
of
um uh culture where
um people who want to find the new
champions actively go into
um diver you know the areas
are with um a lot of
diversity and because you know the
people who are
seem to be more passionate about sports
are usually not not to white
children and they they go
where they know they find a passion and
it's usually
in um areas which are
represented by more diverse
cultures than the average
middle class white background so yes
there is definitely um
a positive and active
support network that murray has not told
me exactly which
support but people who are looking for
the next champions
go actively find um these people
that's a it's really interesting because
i remember after the france won the
world cup i watched a
video about um how the french
national team or from a young age they
recruit players from i think just the
outskirts of france they have a lot of
um
football clubs around there so i didn't
know they were doing a sort of similar
thing for cycling that sounds really
good i hope uh
i hope british british cycling are
listening yeah
i think they are i think i think they
are indeed
um so scouting scouting i think um
there's i'm just going to mention one
one i'm going to mention somebody a guy
called christian
lights who um who um
um became um three times well junior
champion
um um danny might know who he is
actually because um
around during your time and he actually
was scouted
um and i think there were some british
cycling coaches that went around to his
school
and he did a power test and he came up
really well and then he got
to the talent team he won quite a few
national medals and he became the world
union champion because of that that
system that is occurring in france i'm
not sure
the extent that occurs in um
around the country today i don't think
it's as active as it was
but it seems to be working really well
in in france
good question good question
um um rihanna did you have a question
for anyone
um or yeah yeah i've got a question for
danny
uh so i was just wondering how easy did
you find it to access information
about track cycling because we all know
it's a very niche and
like specialized sport which is
incredibly hard to get into
so yeah yeah that's a very good question
actually because other than watching the
london 2012 games i knew nothing about
it um and as a as i'd already mentioned
about stumbling across sally hall
cycling club
if it wasn't for them i don't think i
would have
had a clue how to get into cycling i
wouldn't have known
the closest melodrome or anything
uh like that and it was only for them um
giving me a club track bike to use and
giving me dates of dh
how uh sprint schools and rsars that
british cycling run
uh for how i got into it really um
so yeah i definitely think uh
more awareness um could be
made um and information on how
accessible
um getting into uh sports such as track
cycling i mean cycling is
such a known sport if you say to anyone
you know what cycling is compared to
short track speed skate and they'll go
oh yeah of course riding a bike but then
if you ask them why is your closest
velodrome or
um cycling uh track that's you know
close roads in a safe environment to
ride your bike
um they probably wouldn't be able to
answer that um
so i definitely think that whether
something's done
um you know in schools for instance i
mean
most school children are introduced to
athletics running netball um swimming
even with school sports but uh cycling's
never in there and i mean i know
financially it might be more of a burden
having
to pay for bikes and equipment but is
that something that could be done
um so it introduces children of that age
where they're likely to um really get a
passion
and uh liking for something can could
potentially
uh you know discover that they are the
next
uh champion if you like so maybe that's
something that could be looked into
um and yeah as i say i didn't even know
my cycle track
which was a really safe environment to
learn to ride a bike which i did
um was two miles from my house and a
mile from my school
so very good question yeah great
question
it's about being aware of what the
facilities are
in the neighborhood and also having that
conduit that person
from that particular club going to the
schools um
and becoming a familiar friendly face
with the children at the school and the
teachers there so that they come over
and it's a point made by edward warden
in the chat as well
clubs also need to develop and support
youth sections
this is often a challenge for clubs and
leave
fellow park could also do more to
support involvement i'm gonna go to
marie
marie did you have any did you have any
particular question
for either danny charlotte or reality
did you have a question that you want
just to get to know more about each
other i have just
a question for
um have you ever experienced some kind
of discrimination or racism
um what's in a competition or just
training or yes
okay that's we'd like to go with that
one
um we'd like to go with that one any any
um any
indirect or direct forms of
racial discrimination in your in your
racing careers and
how you dealt with that danny do you
want to go first
yeah i'll go first because i haven't got
a massive uh
answer um i mean i've never experienced
any discrimination
however the only point i've kind of felt
is
my last name is khan and i feel that a
lot of people
they're not scared but they're kind of
intrigued and they shy away from
asking about it and to me it's just
that's my name
so ask away and i know a lot of people
like
i don't know i kind of had a sense that
they'd be talking about that like why is
her last name upon
um you know it is a pakistani name and
that's where my heritage mixed heritage
comes from so
yeah that's the only point i have
for that question sense of curiosity
yeah yeah no discrimination
or anything like that but just yeah just
an intrigue really
and i have had a few coaches come up in
the past and
kind of say can i ask why your last name
is khan and it's
yeah they feel a bit almost uncomfy but
it's not
nothing to me it's my name so
good response charlotte
um yeah i mean again it's a really good
question because
um a lot of the time i think if you have
um
if you've spent most done most of your
cycling career when you're quite young
which is i think the case for most of us
because we're all quite young still
well i'm holding on to that um and then
you there are a lot of things that you
might kind of dismiss um
at the time i mean it's obvious if
someone if someone hurls a racial slur
you
you you know that that's racism but
there are some more subtle things so um
and i tell this story a lot so i won't
go into too much detail but
when i um when i raced in the
netherlands for the first time and i was
only 12 years old
um i was uh i was the i was the british
champion at the time on the road so i
had the little the jersey with the
stripes on
so i was quite identifiable but i was
also quite tall and i think i talked a
bit too much in the bunch for
most people's liking um and they
there there was um a weird rumor that
went round and someone complained to the
commissars at the end of one of the
stages
or not someone um eight girls had told
the commissars that i pulled their hair
during the race um which i think is such
a strange and absurd lie
but obviously if eight people complain
about it it really makes it seem like
it's
it was true um so i had i had to have a
conversation with the commissar
and eventually you know she she
watched the final stage at the top of
the car and determined that
you know there was no there was no
problem when i was racing i wasn't doing
anything
wrong or but i i you know i
i don't know why they didn't like me but
i
you know i wouldn't be surprised if it's
because of the way i looked
um and again that that same race
you know someone in my club did have a
was
a racial slur was shouted at him by
someone in the race just one person
in the race who was who was told off
about it but so yeah you kind of come
into contact with things and you
question yourself about
certain incidents as well um which makes
it difficult but
yeah thanks for sharing that charlotte
you've shared that with me before and
it shows you it shows you that you can
you can be targeted
rihanna um any any any responses to
maurice question just
uh similar to charlotte you never really
know to be fair unless obviously someone
says it straight out loud
um on a scare at the international
in january my parents came and told me
they got refused from
not refused because they didn't manage
they just went upstairs in the end
but um the officials and some people
there didn't believe that they were
they were comments they were um
spectating
they said no no respect there is my
daughter's um my daughter's
basically no no i'm not here not you you
need to go back downstairs
oh god no um
somebody just said no we just we just
ended up going upstairs but yeah no
no direct no direct but indirect
possibly yes but
you just you would just never know
really it seems that you've had an
experience of being an interloper you
know like
you spoke about the first experience in
terms of when you went to do cycle
and that type of visit that hyper
visibility and
at the national championships you
because of your identity
it's assumed that you're not an athlete
it's just not good enough is it and
um you know i've been writing my book
is finished now um but there are some
more
um experiences not just in the current
day
it's it's disgusting that this sort of
attitude's occurring in the current day
um but it's it's it's a historical thing
and um hopefully
we'll be able to share that this this
sort of attitude is something that needs
to be
wiped out and there needs to be a lot of
education it's a great question marie
it's a fantastic question and it brings
me on to this
go on charlotte yeah can i ask um if
you've had the
your experiences are uh yes um
i was i think like um 12
or 13 years old i go on because
it was the first time i left my region
for a competition
and this competition um
of the friends and
when i meet other children of the
foundation they
we are
so there were only two black within her
team
yeah yeah from that into it was an
inter-county um competition
and the other children
say to in uzundi um
go eat your banana and
it was it was the first time i
because
yeah and until that point she never felt
any different but
it was this kind of like turning point
where she experienced it
as a shock and it changed
changed the way she was aware of
her identity
it's it's it's actually i think um it's
really difficult
in a different way to when you
experience it throughout your whole life
when you're really aware of it being
there
it kind of it it you become so used to
it but then if you're not
used to it and it happens one time it
just completely catches you off guard
it's really difficult to deal with
because you think this is i don't know
how to react to this it's so
strange and alien because i i just
i don't expect it you know yeah it's
these are shocking stories and they're
they're horrible
um psychological um memories to
to have to carry um in doing
something that you really love doing
but having having that um ugliness
fester into
your world and aiming to interfere with
what you're doing
is is is just shocking and um
you know that there needs to be um
you know parents in the sport coaches in
a sport who
um know who know what this sort of
behavior
um need to be rooted out you know and
and need to be educated
um because it can't happen but um
i guess marie you've let your legs do
the talking you've become the world
champion
and so you charlotte and rihanna this is
going to happen for you in the future
and same for you danny you've let your
legs do the talking
and i just want to show you a picture of
them
of of uh of another um champion
and this um what a couple of them
actually
um you've got selena alvarado from
from the netherlands and you've got
tiniel campbell and um
they've come to the scene as leading
lights today
um and um you know the press that the
cycling media give them quite a lot of
attention
there's nobody out there on the track i
mean most of us here are
track cyclists both of these are out
like
individuals um you know so
what else what else can be done to um
um i'm not gonna actually you know what
else can be done to sort of
um introduce more bame
cyclists to track cycling um in in
in the uk um so that they can become
just
as well known as these two but also as
successful
as some of you in your in your
sports as well who would like to tackle
that question what more can
what more can be done who needs to be
supporting and financing development
at grassroots level
um i'm happy today um
i think well i've started i think like
nationally involving bodies definitely
need to have a detail
but um for from my point of view i came
from athletics and i i think
athletics and parking can be very
interchangeable if you're a
long-distance runner you're probably
going to be
endurance athlete on the bike if you're
a sprinter you can probably
do this printing on the bike so i think
definitely scouting at other sports
which you could sort of
looking to preparing scientists maybe
and just
actively scouting more which we touched
on earlier with
how um we're doing it in france
it's a good response so using sort of
athletics as a
model framework um and sort of taking
that framework almost a bit like the
great britain athletics team
50 years ago they were probably all
white athletes weren't there but now
today
in 2021 it's very much a multicultural
team
cycling hasn't gifted cycling you know
cycling as a national team was pretty
much
white in the 1960s is pretty much white
today so
good answer good answer charlotte danny
how are we going to produce um
more what some more you know how are we
going to grow
some b-a-m-e young female
world champions in great britain danny
have you got any ideas
yeah i mean it's quite a challenging uh
topic really
um and as i've touched on before an
awareness at a school level i think
would be um especially at secondary
school
level where children are kind of 12 to
16 years i think that's
where you kind of decide if you're going
to go into career in
sport and whether something could be
done that when
athletes retire they could go into like
a training
program to be a coach and especially
with
females i mean personally um i think
more female coaches
would be brilliant i know for a fact i
would have liked to have had a female
coach
um to have worked with um throughout my
years on the national team uh within the
track environment as well so
whether that can be something done from
grassroots
right until the elite end um i mean the
uk if you look for example
we're really privileged to have all that
financial
support whereas other countries um
i mean like most of europe they have
great facilities and accessibility
to facilities so i think that there is
definitely room for
um coaches and that could also help with
the skeleton as well they could be going
round and looking at the sports
um kind of yeah just creating that
awareness really and showing that the
opportunities
are there but it's just having the
knowledge um
for that um but yeah having having more
coaches female coaches as role models as
well i think that would
inspire people and um encourage really
and not
make people think it's um oh it's
cycling we should just stick to
athletics or
what is known if you like so yeah just
really creating that awareness for me
um in all that yeah
that's that's a great answer and you
know over the last sort of few years
there have been quite a few um bame
um led female groups coming together to
sort of raise the profile of sight
killing
and i know that british cycling are
aiming to um
to to work as well as they can with
these groups a woman of color cycling
group
um they started off in london and
they're more
spread around the country evolve
recycling group
um based in london hertfordshire and
spokes um spokes out are based in derby
um as well so there are some groups
out there that are aiming to sort of um
generate
a wider pool of female
coaches um so hopefully
that that that is something that's
growing but also um
they do need role models and they do
need to see people like you
um and charlotte and rihanna more often
um on the scene um talking about your
stories and your
you know you know your fantastic
experiences
um let me just ask last you know just
that question to marie marie um
is there an issue um with with with
growing
more black female cyclists in in france
or do you have a conveyor belt um
coming after you are there going to be
more marie divines coming through
in france or do you think there's an
issue i was
the only woman the other black people
was a boy so
uh yeah it's it's a it's uh
it's different yeah
okay so can i just store it can i just
quickly add in
i think um what marie does is really
good because
i actually seen her on instagram it was
when she won her world title
at junior world and i started following
her instagram and that instagram page is
just brilliant
because and then i looked it and i
thought no this is so cool like
and as like another black person like
seeing that was just amazing and the
content she puts
the content that she puts out is like
really relatable and inspirational and
you're like
she can do it i can do it and it's like
really good if we have more people like
her
i'm gonna try and do myself like all of
us we're pretty i think we're pretty
instagram savvy i'm definitely not going
to work on
but what marie does like has content she
puts out she makes us heard
and then that means that after younger
generations on socials all the time
you see and you see me redo that it's
like so cool just like positive
and everything it's like guys and
[ __ ] good partners
dedicated to the training i think it's
really cool
now that's that's such a valid point i
think um
i don't know i mean you know when when i
saw that marie won that world
championships and
some some of the photographs and i was
told by um
some friends of the vco i think it was
olivier
nielsen julian said that you that you
belted up the national anthem from
top at the top of your voice when you
won that world championships
and everyone could hear you but the very
fact is that you know
it it shows it shows young um black
people that you know young black females
that it can be done
and um and so it's quite inspirational
to see that
i think when you do it with a smile a
smile on your face as well
that is so much more inspirational that
is why i was thinking about this you
know
these these kind of pictures of celine
alvarado and tanil campbell
that can inspire young black
girls to think wait a minute they're
really enjoying themselves in this sport
maybe i could do it as well
we just need to see more of that you
know more young
um black um girls really showing that
they love the sport
and you know and young but asian girls
found that they
they really love the sport and that will
draw younger people in i think
um so some great answers there
let me um let me just uh spend five more
minutes or so
okay just talking about um
talking about what's uh happening next
okay um for
for um some of you so what what's coming
up next so we've got
um we've got these events coming up next
week
i've got birmingham 2022 um
we've got the world championships in
glasgow in 2023
and paris 2024 i'm not saying that tokyo
2021
is not going to happen but who knows we
need to look i guess we need to look
beyond that
but um let me ask you a question of
of danny about this first of all first
of all 2022 and
with you um coming from solihull
um and this you know this international
event being so close to your home i mean
is there any way in which you'll be
taking part in this
event at birmingham at the commonwealth
games danny
um i'd absolutely love to um it'd be a
dream goal of mine it would be my second
commonwealth games
i competed at glasgow in 2014 as a track
sprinter
uh but since then i have um now
transferred over to
endurance cycling um so
yeah i would absolutely love to be there
competing for england um more
specifically on the track
uh in the endurance bunch races such as
the scratch the points
and maybe the team pursuit but
ultimately that
means i need to get on the track and
with the current restrictions uh it's
been quite
tricky for me to try and get access to
training
on a velodrome so that uh hopes slowly
fading away because
obviously i need to put myself up for
selection it's not gonna happen from
zwift on my garage unfortunately as many
hours as i'm doing and
how fantastic that's been as a training
tool
um and still keeping that sense of
community going was
the you know the current pandemic but um
yeah i mean i'd absolutely
love to go um especially being from
sally hall in birmingham
um glasgow was a home games but this is
even more a home game so it'd be
fantastic
no i think you i think it would be
fantastic uh for you
but also um to encourage um younger
females
in cycling that you know that there are
home
grown champions who are still doing a
sport and who are taking part in those
games
on our doorstep so i i do know that
you've been speaking with david weiner
as well um the president of houzz owen
um fighting club about about the
possibility of of of the building of a
velodrome in the west midlands how about
that yeah that would be fantastic
and i actually said to him on a email um
in the leader to the junior worlds in
2013
my dad was driving me because obviously
i hadn't passed my driving test i was uh
only 16 17 um and i hadn't passed my
driving test he was driving me to
manchester three times a week
um that was whilst he was working and i
was in full time education at
sally hall sixth form college so that
was um that made for a hectic week
and having a local facility there would
have obviously taken that pressure off
so obviously for myself but in the
future of the sport i know how much that
would
be grateful and appreciated especially
as birmingham is quite a major city and
um i think there could be a lot of again
a lot of cyclists that
would prosper from that um yeah we could
get some
get some more into it and yeah if i
could help that in a
any small way it would be fantastic so
that would be fantastic but very much
you know it's very diverse
in the west midlands and if that if that
velodrome were given the go ahead and it
would put in an
area um of the west midlands that that
that attracts uh
um more ethnic diversity than then
that's that's another way of growing
this
world i was looking for the word attract
what happened
what about um what about the national
question um
marie um doing about paris 2024
um
um about paris 2024 murray i mean is
this something that you haven't
have on your mind already
um now i i can imagine uh
uh perry24 because um it's um
it's my track i i i'm on the train
all the day on this track
my home it's like uh to 30 minutes
my friends my parents my family
all people is
[Music]
i hope to to win i hope to become uh
olympic champion and
i i have to to work hard and
now i want i just want to
to to progress to
progress yes yes yes
and and i think
it's it's gonna be it's gonna be
incredible
yeah i know step by step of course i
think um
i think it it's it's it could be a
fantastic opportunity for what it's
gonna be a
fantastic opportunity for you personally
but also
um to to raise your profile as a
magnificent
you know a champion athlete for
people in france but also as a role
model for
young black psycho athletes around the
world and
hopefully things will go well for you um
and hopefully we'll be able to see you
um in
in glasgow in 2023 before that um
where um where where scotland are
hosting the world's
um cycling championships as well so um
now that's gonna be a fantastic
opportunity to see more of you marie
and um i know that um i know that um you
rihanna you're you're aiming to sort of
raise your profile as well
at future national championships and and
possibly to
move on to future in international
sports events as well can you tell us a
bit more about that
yeah definitely um get some times on the
walls basically
um nationals yeah uh get them test them
out hopefully
um yeah never say another 2023 olympics
obviously you've got a you've got to set
your goal for otherwise
yeah hopefully good things are coming
yeah well yeah exactly we've got to get
more times on the board
so so um let's see what happens
um in terms of how we go in that
response and charlotte can i ask you
about your um
your valuable experience in racing in
coaching
and in leading discussions on diversity
inclusion which of these are
other priorities for you now is it
racing is it coaching or is it
or is it doing something else in in the
sport
um well my biggest priority is is
watching marie win at 2024.
uh no i mean
yeah all of the things that i um i can
do
to help uh to help our sport progress to
help more people
be introduced to the sport it's
interesting this this um
this discussion has kind of has opened
my eyes in a way that a lot of others
that have that i've participated in
haven't and made me think about
a little bit more about um the culture
of cycling in
in the uk and that is something we need
to tackle i think
um there's this weird uh weird hatred
for
for cyclists and cycling which i think
feeds into why it's a sort of uh
weirdly unknown sport and a weirdly um
kind of niche sport so anything that can
be done to
to get more people not just um to the
highest
level of of cycling but just involved
more people
commuting more people watching more
people
interested um in in any way and uh yeah
and doing
coaching in uh at my local club and you
know hopefully
maybe uh on a bigger
on a big on a higher scale some someday
so maybe um
when you guys are winning the olympics i
can be there coaching carrying your
your wheels around or something uh but
yeah
you know i think it's really important
that we even even
um whilst everyone is still racing at a
high level we take some time to
to volunteer at our local clubs and and
give back and do things like this as
well which are obviously really
important and have
engaged a large audience and and um
and hopefully will have some impact in
in the direction the sport goes
um so anything i can do to to help
really
well absolutely and and this this this
international chesapeake
has been called young powerful women and
you know absolutely you know you are
young powerful women you've
lived the sports you've you've um you've
worked hard you've had that you've
had the hard days you've had the good
days you've become champions
your young voices for younger people
coming up in the future i think
um people listening now um the cycling
industry
would do well to get in contact with you
guys
immediately so that they can have you um
directing them in the sport for the
future it's been a fantastic discussion
it really has
um i want to thank you very much for
your time today danny
sharla rihanna and marie it's been a
privilege
it's been a pleasure being with you
today i wish you all the best for the
rest of the
year in the future i hope to work with
you again
um very soon um thank you to all of the
people who've come to listen to this
discussion as well i hope you've learned
a lot
hope um any policymakers out there
listening we'll take on board some of
these fantastic comments made by these
cyclists
and we'll get to action straight away um
because these are real
lived experiences that um that
are true to their words and are going to
help to inform
policy and action in the future so do
take notes
thank you everyone for joining us and
watching um
and just one big wave goodbye to
everybody really we've gone over our
time
thank you very much for the opportunity
nausica thank you very much as well um
have a good rest of the evening
everybody and
uh take care i'll see you at the next
live talk
thank you very much thank you very much
everyone
thanks charlotte thanks rihanna thanks
marie thank you
bye bye
you